head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
I am of the view that women's suffrage
changed politics for the worse because I
think it opened the um floodgates to uh
opportunistic
Charming sociopaths who might previously
have been weeded out or considered not
the right kind of person sometimes you
see glimpses of this in I mean if you
watch Mary Poppins right and the dad
who's kind of like vilified
um Mr Banks is the only virtuous
character in the whole thing
um and and he's talking about how
discipline order and an essential
English virtue restraint are the basis
of a well-functioned of a orderly
civilization
um and and those are the those are the
virtues the values the the um habits
that we should uh aspire to and all
around it he's got this
um he's got this uh pampered
um prideful mess of a wife who can't be
bothered to be a mother uh and it's
churning through nannies instead because
she's um you know got her whatever uh
there's there's this um witch who
descends from the sky and and you know
uh gives the kids psychedelic drugs I
guess
um uh we gotta remake this movie and
tells it no it's already down there
um uh you know and and um uh uh she she
kind of um wears the thin veneer of
rules and manners but really she
preaches chaos
um and she under and you know she she
undermine there's stuff in that movie
that that is on purpose like uh in um in
uh feed the birds you know she she she
she has the audacity to claim knowledge
of what the Saints
think about uh you know Airborne rodents
uh pooping on Cathedrals uh damaging the
architecture uh it's it's a very
subversive movie about the Triumph of
Witchcraft over over a virtue but
um
you know uh is that what it is
Mary Poppins oh it's hideous it's
fascinating no it's very it's very dark
it's very dark um you have this you have
this we got to do we got like we have to
do like a thing where we watch it and
you do like a director's commentary kind
of thing where you explain there's a
show in Britain I think called gogglebox
where where the the show is two people
on a couch talking about the show
they're watching and it sounds like
unendurable but it's really good Bobble
box goggle box I think I've never seen
it but but the but the um everybody
everybody loves it uh no I mean there's
so much in that movie you know to unpack
the way that she um she presents as as
um as a as an appropriate
um
uh candidate for the the role
um but then immediately sets about
wrecking the social order
um and it's a it's a particular kind of
uh
Christian restraint that um Mr Banks is
is is explaining he's you know he's
saying that we can't just give in to
every uh Reckless and wild uh abandoned
Temptation he's saying you know in order
in order to prosper and to be happy and
to be successful and to and for and for
our ancestors
um to be proud of us and our descendants
to be grateful to us
um there are virtues we should cleave to
that involve not indulging ourselves and
what does Mary Poppins come and do she
comes in and and makes a makes a mockery
of the business of of tidying the room
by using witchcraft uh so there's no
effort expended
um uh violating the natural order of
things and teaching the kids that um uh
they can do their chores without the
effort required and therefore they don't
learn lessons from it she takes them on
this psychedelic Journey teaching them
nonsense words uh she uh Praises Praises
uh
um I mean you won't know this as
Americans but you don't feed pigeons in
London they're rats with wings that's
what that's what we call them you know
this this lullaby to to send people to
sleep
um is is is is about encouraging
um a Vermin that has destroyed the
architecture of London you know
everything in that movie is about
um undermining or overturning uh the the
natural order of things and this is this
is what uh the
headless selfish prideful mother wrapped
up in her own political
escapades neglecting her duties as a
mother is engaged in she's engaged in
the Brazilians now the reason that I uh
abhor women's suffrage is not that it
was something women just demand demand
demanded that they don't deserve or that
they're not capable of executing
actually it was a a manifestation of
cowardice from the men because it was a
way of saying you're on your own handle
yourself I'm not responsible for your
decision making and therefore I can't be
held accountable for what happens yeah
afterwards women's suffrage was a result
of a crisis of confidence in the men and
this was greatly enhanced and
um and concentrated by the two world
wars that Europe uh experienced where
men I think basically
um lost the
they felt like they lost the right to
rule uh they felt like they'd wrecked
the world I mean it's difficult for us
from this distance to appreciate
the unfathomable you know Psychopathic
horrors of the Third Reich you know uh
in whatever manifestation you choose to
believe you know whichever
configuration of historical fact they're
all terrible
um
how a well-ordered Christian Society
gets to the point of going along with
that is something that ought to haunt
all of us and it haunted everybody
um because people like had friends in
Germany and they're like how could you
send your kiss to Hillary youth Well
everybody's in the hill Earth it's just
like the scouts the the way that that
country got swept up in it it's
something dark and dangerous about human
nature that we are yet to really
understand it's the obsession with
religion as an institution that's really
done Christianity dirty man to say that
it's out there and if I think those
things then I don't have to live like
Jesus was you got to live like Jesus
that's your job as a Christian then you
in you embody the Christ that's all we
need well I'm Catholic so I can't agree
with your uh heretical opening um but
but certainly we should look to Christ
as an example to live by
um but you know Christ is not um Christ
is not an emotionally incontinent person
in the gospels I don't think he ever
laughs
um he's quite a serious guy and
says quite outrageous things things you
couldn't say on YouTube and
he is actually quite a profoundly
serious figure despite the Great Joy he
brings into the World by his uh his his
selflessness his sacrifice I feel but
very interestingly
what he what he lays down for us
um is what became you know the great
classic English virtue of restraint it's
uh I'm gonna I'm gonna say no because I
I understand that there are consequences
that come with short-term pleasure and
this really is the most useful lesson
that anybody can teach their children
and Mary Poppins is a is just an
extended
um uh it's an extended
undermining of the most valuable lesson
that any parent can teach their child
yeah and when you look at modern
entertainment you do see a lot of those
themes regurgitated and exaggerated
especially with someone else yeah it's
unwatchable because it's not
entertainment it's propaganda a lot of
it is is sometimes if we're lucky it's
subconscious and subliminal but many
times it's overt in your face the larger
messaging of not just degeneracy
short-term Pleasures but but just also
destroying not only race relations sex
relations but destroying kind of
humanity from the inside with this
psychological Mass hypnosis as I call it
the individual all subject matter are
all you know arguable and and will
probably agree about all of that but the
real characteristic that it that it has
um the way to understand it because it's
happened before in history
um the the nature of its character it's
nature is that we're entering a late
decadent period of gloating that is
common to all um illegitimate tyrannies
uh and the one we have right now is
something that Orwell didn't foresee a
weird blend of private Enterprise and
government
um run by the same people
um who operate both for their exclusive
enrichment and which has impoverished
all of us in spiritual ways in financial
ways in all kinds of ways uh culturally
you name it in in every conceivable way
our lives and our society are getting
dramatically worse with each day that
passes and and my decision personally
has been to refuse to play along with
that and I won't operate within those
rules because I think it's um
I think it's beneath the Dignity of a
human being to do so
um I don't mean that as a I don't mean
that as an insult to you guys because I
I admire the discipline that it takes
and I I understand the calculus that
you've made right we're gonna we're
gonna say less but to more people I
totally get it
um and and there's there's a there's a
spectrum on which we all operate I'm on
the opposite end to you guys so um you
guys and I have taken a different
strategy to the same problem
um both are right and both are needed
you know I just you know we just we just
are on opposite ends of it
um but the the this this late this
gloating the um the gleefulness with
which they um Revel in their
unaccountable and untrammeled power over
us is intolerable and unsustainable and
when that happens
um in history the empire in question
typically Falls really quickly shortly
thereafter and when big nation when big
Empires fall they don't fall like you
think they're going to they don't kind
of ossify they don't um disintegrate
they evaporate uh it happened to Rome it
happened to the USSR and it will happen
to America the the yeah the vector for
America is probably going to be the
Petro Dollar in the Dollar General I I
asked you about uh the the loss of I
guess we don't care about Legacy anymore
or at least many do but many don't it's
a shift in priorities from the widening
of the lecturer right actually you
mentioned this I wanted to specifically
go in in that direction you're saying
that women don't care about Legacy as
much as men do or what's the what's the
how does that how does that happen a
system working perfectly um is a system
where everything is in its right place
uh performing the function for which it
was designed okay and if any if any
component in that system is improperly
utilized or damaged or in the wrong
place the whole thing can seize up and
sometimes it can it can be destroyed a
fine watch from a Swiss watchmaker will
be uh
irretrievably wrecked by a component
being moved from here to here you know
you can't you can't fix it
I mean they're very expensive ones but
you get the point
we I take the same view of creation
um we ought not tamper with um
uh
the order that has been laid out for us
and there are different distinct
um equal but different I suppose people
want to say
um there are distinct I don't think they
are equal I think women are greatly
venerated and always have been
um and when women ask for equality with
men I I'm of the view that they are
silly in asking for a demotion
um
what we shouldn't tamper with is the
proper order of things there's a proper
order to the physical world to the
natural world that reflects the Heavenly
order that represents the supernatural
that reflects the supernatural right
um it's an echo of it and when we have
men doing things that women should be
doing and women doing things that men
should be doing and when we commingle
the definitions of those two things
um we risk the whole system falling down
and I think that's what's happening uh I
think that's what we're witnessing uh
and Camille Paglia the uh feminist
critic
um says that uh the one characteristic
uh an infallible guide to imminent
collapse in
all great civilizations in the past is
an obsession with uh she calls it a kind
of gender Madness right
um without getting into the subject uh
uh in in in a way that would be
dangerous
um
a preoccupation with um Innovative and
sometimes confusing new definitions of
things they're sort of confusing of this
fundamental natural this is the moment
at which civilizations lose their way
and they don't last long after that
so um I think that um it is a man's
responsibility to project and to provide
I think that um men go out and create
all these extraordinary things
ultimately to impress women when men
want to impress other men they take
creatine and work out that's always for
other men uh women don't care about
about physics so much that's always for
for men
um something sort of intrinsically
homosexual about that but
um when men go out and and Achieve these
great feats uh building civilizations
you know constructing Cathedrals all
right so it's um it's because they want
access they want in and they want to you
know that that it's a it's a it's a
romantic project
and
it's beneath the Dignity of
of wives and mothers
uh who have a far more important purpose
on Earth to
give them you know the petty workings of
these political experiments that men
have come up with to occupy themselves
um to to to you know distract them with
that stuff and and I don't think it's
something that um women especially love
I mean women kind of hint this uh except
they send us subtle indications that
this might be the case
um you see very often women kind of
adopt the politics of their husbands
um it's kind of a phenomenon that um uh
is actually it's actually more
pronounced the more extreme that the
husband's politics are so you have um uh
you have these these women who fall in
love with like jihadis and they adopt
you know radical Islam and then they go
husband surfing because their husbands
all you know kind of do suicide bombings
um they Bounce from husband's husband
but they start off you know like
perfectly normal uh Jihad Jane Jihad
Jenny there's a semester Samantha loose
weight loads of examples of this women
who just kind of adopt any politics at
all uh to get the guy right and this is
their way of telling us that they don't
really care you know it's just like they
have other priorities they want to feel
safe they want to feel secure they want
to feel loved provided for protected and
part of doing that is um is sparing
women from
the ugly
baffling and frankly squalid world of
politics full of opportunists and freaks
and inappropriate people you know
they're all the people who want power
right the people in politics uh and so
we we suffer them you think women
shouldn't be in politics
um I think that in America because
American men are so
um uh
are so utterly pathetic
um uh all talk and no action that when I
find American women much more impressive
than American men and there are lots of
examples of women having to step up
where men have left vacuums I think
Marjorie tell a green is an example of
that
um she will readily readily tell you
that in a perfect world she wouldn't
have to be doing this but she felt that
it was necessary and that she was the
right person the right time
um because because no man is doing it
for her so so I see her as a as a kind
of um a sort of a Boudicca uh Joan of
Arc kind of a warrior Queen archetype
you know she's doing the thing that no
man will step up and do and you know
every couple of hundred years men need
to need a reminder like that that
they're um uh uh that they're renewing
on their responsibilities uh I don't
think it's the proper Arena of women to
to concern themselves with uh you know
the the intricacies of politics uh
because they have a higher and Holier
and much more important purpose
um to which their skills are better
suited and I I think that when you when
you know when when in in the two world
wars and women flooded the mock the
workplace out of necessity uh and then
you have you know they mention the
washing machine which frees up this
enormous amount of time
um
once women had been well uh pleaded with
to to come and keep think keep the the
factory Line running uh nobody felt they
had the right coming back from War when
they direct the world to say all right
back in the kitchen love
um so so they just sort of accepted the
new the new reality
we can see what's we can see what's
happened as a result there's there's
been a feminizing of our institutions
police forces have started to act more
like School teachers where they're kind
of scolding people for using the wrong
language rather than uh uh you know
criminals there's all kinds of hints
that the priorities that the mission
statements that the uh modus operandi of
our of our state institutions and and
now private Enterprises too have have
changed and I I don't think for the
better uh as a result of of um
what was Miss sold to women as
emancipation and was actually their
enslavement would you would you advocate
for repealing the 19th Amendment
absolutely
for those I don't know it's the women's
right to vote we owe women
um an enormous apology for the
imposition that we placed on them
um by this Grievous ongoing offense
subjecting them to the ugliness of
politics when they should be concerned
with uh raising the Next Generation and
and perpetuating the dynasty which is of
course the thing that the man is
worrying about and finds it you know he
finds a wife that he believes will be a
partner with him in that Pro in that in
that task
um and while he's having these grandiose
uh um thoughts and and building these
extraordinary structures it's the women
that are doing the hard work of raising
the Next Generation they can't do both
um and I think now we've seen and women
are beginning to admit in columns in the
Atlantic and elsewhere that they
couldn't do both and they wish they'd
done the other one thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time